blast light is the world's smallest
and most convenient uvc disinfection
light to help keep you safe
against covid19 i take mine everywhere i
go
go to davidpakman.com
to get it for 40 off the link is down
below
so there's a new report out that while
shocking
shouldn't be hugely surprising to
anybody who's been paying attention for
the last six years
uh in a new book by wall street journal
reporter michael bender
bender writes that donald trump
told his then chief of staff john kelly
in 2018
that hitler yes adolf hitler
did a lot of good things now remember
that the wall street journal is owned by
news corporation that's the same company
that owns fox news this is not some
left-wing
publication or left-wing reporter the
story
goes that this took place during a visit
to europe for the 100th anniversary of
the end of world war one now you might
i actually remember this was one of the
many disastrous trips that trump took
and i believe this was the one where he
ended up not going somewhere and they
claimed it was because of fog but he
just wanted to hang around and watch fox
news there was like some leaf ring
wreath laying ceremony something like
that i believe that's the same trip here
and during that trip donald trump
insisted to john kelly
who at the time was his chief of staff
that well hitler did a lot of good
things
um the comments reportedly stunned
john kelly this is all in a book that's
hilariously titled
frankly we did win this election uh you
know that's that's uh trump the guy of
course who who is saying that
congratulations sir you just won the
election yeah
um now the comment itself is outrageous
and stunning there are rumors that trump
used to keep a copy of hitler's speeches
on his bedside table
trump doesn't read that's the one thing
that makes me doubt that but it's
certainly possible
but the context here is actually even
more interesting trump apparently
blurted this out
during the trip when john kelly started
explaining basic history to trump i
guess as was frequently done
um before an event people around trump
would try to give him
a little information about how the world
works so that he would maybe be able to
avoid humiliating himself
and in so doing john kelly reminded
trump
what were the different countries on
each side of world war one
and then kelly explained how world war
one connected to world war ii and of
course the holocaust and the atrocities
of adolf hitler and in that context
trump's um contribution trump's
interjection was well hitler did a lot
of good things
it's an american president folks
reportedly saying this
now of course trump's new spokeswoman
liz harrington
says it's all made up she says quote
this is
totally false president trump never said
this
it has made up fake news probably by a
general
who was incompetent and was fired
however bender seems to have done his
job
and his homework and has multiple
sources on this and in fact multiple
people told bender
everybody in the room was saying to
trump no no no no no
hitler didn't do great things and they
were clearly horrified that trump
might say that publicly at some point
and trump reportedly insisted according
to multiple sources no
hitler did do great things like for
example
leading the german economic recovery in
the 1930s now
even that shows trump's complete
ignorance and his deference
to authoritarian and in some cases
genocidal uh
leaders trump seems to have no idea that
the so-called german economic revival
was hugely based on wealth that they
stole
from the people that they eventually
murdered uh
what i would have given to have been a
fly on the wall
during this conversation and bender adds
in the book that kelly told trump
even if your claim about the german
economy
under the nazis was true like even if it
were true
that hitler did great things
economically quote
you cannot ever say anything supportive
of adolf hitler you just can't
and kelly clearly realized that if he
didn't explain that to trump
next thing you know trump might be
praising hitler in public
and the book more generally outlines how
clueless
trump was about every aspect of history
quote senior officials described his
understanding of slavery
jim crow or the black experience in
general post-civil war
as vague to non-existent but trump's
indifference to black history
was similar to his disregard for the
history of
any race religion or creed
it's actually crazy but this sounds like
the type of things some trump supporters
would actually say in defending trump
like when you confront a trump supporter
and you say listen trump is really
authoritarian
his tendencies are like duterte
and they're like kim jong-un and they're
like putin and you know
some aspects are even hitlerian in some
way
okay man but hitler did some good things
i mean the economy did well and the
trains ran
on time or whatever it sounds exactly
like the prototypical trump supporter
and
i don't typically read these types of
books i didn't read fire and fury i
didn't read you know all of these
different ones
uh frankly we did win this election
sounds like one i may actually want to
look at but certainly nothing
shock it's shocking but it's not a
surprise
if you've been following donald trump
for as long as anybody who's been
following american politics has been
doing it
and uh curious to see if trump will say
anything about it himself
hey you know i am i am starting to think
that when congresswoman marjorie taylor
green apologized for comparing things to
the holocaust
it may not have been a completely
sincere apology because she is yet again
saying that things joe biden is doing
are like
the nazis um the uh business insider
is reporting marjorie taylor green
compares
biden's vaccine push to nazis
weeks after apologizing for comparing
mass mandates to the holocaust
congresswoman marjorie taylor-green
compared biden's vaccination push
to the nazi brown shirts this came weeks
after she apologized for comparing other
covid19 guidelines to the nazis that was
when she said nancy pelosi saying you
have to wear masks on the house floor
uh is uh is i guess like
you know how the jews were treated by
nazis green has a history of promoting
anti-semitic conspiracy theories let's
uh take a look at the tweet she sent out
where she
uh responded to joe biden saying we've
got to go
community to community we've got to go
neighborhood by neighborhood we've got
to go door to door
and just say hey do you want to get
vaccinated marjorie taylor green
tweeting biden pushing a vaccine
that's not fda approved shows
covid is a political tool
used to control people people have a
choice
they don't need your medical brown
shirts
showing up at their door ordering
vaccinations of course nobody would be
ordering it they would just be making it
really really easy to get one hey we're
here do you want a vaccine
here you go you can't force people to be
part of the human
experiment and even that is sort of
alluding
to nazi medical experiments um
come on guys come on and if you have
forgotten or didn't see it
this is marjorie taylor green just a few
weeks ago
realizing that the holocaust was really
bad
and she was wrong to compare nancy
pelosi
to the holocaust okay uh take a look at
that always want to remind everyone
i'm very much a normal person and i
think it's important
for me to always be transparent
and and honest and i just want to tell
you all
i'm i'm really really lucky uh i was
blessed with
i am blessed with amazing parents and my
dad
just passed away in april
but i will say he taught me some great
things
and one of the best lessons that my
father always taught me
was when you make a mistake you should
own it
and i have made a mistake and it's
really bothered me for a couple of weeks
now
and so i definitely want to own it this
afternoon
i visited the holocaust museum the
holocaust
is there's nothing comparable to it
it's it's it happened and
you know over six million jewish people
were murdered
more than that there were not just
jewish people
black people christians all kinds of
children people that that the nazis
didn't believe were good enough
or perfect enough and the horrors of the
holocaust are something that
some people don't even believe happen
and some people deny but there is no
comparison to the holocaust
and there are words that i have said
remarks that i've made
that i know are offensive and for that i
want to apologize
and i am i am just fine
and very glad to be able to come out
here and do that because i believe it's
important
i believe that if we're going to leave
we need to be able to lead in a way
where if we've messed up it's very
important for us to say we're sorry
so you know clearly her apology was
insincere
clearly this is a very very sick woman
clearly this is someone who just can't
get away
from these comparisons to nazis and the
holocaust and all of this stuff
but there is sort of an interesting
conflict here
because marjorie taylor greene is a
massive trump suck-up i mean absolutely
one of the biggest
but she's constantly doing anti-vac
stuff but remember
trump said not that long ago quote
it's a great vaccine it's a safe vaccine
and it's something that works i
recommend it to a lot of people that
don't want to get it
and a lot of those people voted for me
that was trump
saying that even recognizing that
there's lots of anti-vaxx
among his supporters what would marjorie
taylor green
a massive and uh bottomless trump
suck-up
say about the fact that her leader
donald trump is saying hey even the
people who follow me and don't want it
they should go ahead and get it and
they're just continuing to push this
type
of thing here is charlie kirk who's sort
of like a
young young republican group leader this
group called turning point usa charlie
kirk
just compared vaccination guidelines to
apartheid
but more than anything else tucker what
we are going to do is a massive public
relations campaign
and make sure students know they are not
alone they don't have to hide in the
shadows all of a sudden they're
concerned
that if they get the vaccine they're
going to be treated as if there's
there's something that i said this
earlier and this is a big statement but
it's almost this
apartheid style open-air hostage
situation like
oh you can have your freedom back if you
get the jab this is unacceptable we're
going to fight back against it
yeah so again you know they they just
can't get away from this stuff
what's interesting about the charlie
kirk thing is that i have been warning
not as something that we want to divide
people
but is something that is simply going to
happen if you continue
seeing such vaccination rate gaps
between
democrats and republicans between
liberals and conservatives
between biden voters and trump voters
this is going to turn
into a republican pandemic now
of course because the the the uh vaccine
is not 100 effective
even if every democrat got vaccinated
and very few republicans did
some democrats are still going to get
sick you only have 92
protection maybe even slightly lower
against the delta variant we still don't
know the level of protection against the
lambda variant
but there is no doubt that that
vaccination gap
is going to start infecting more and
more republicans than it is democrats if
it's the republicans who overwhelmingly
are refusing
to go and get themselves vaccinated so
sort of
inadvertently stumbling charlie kirk did
across a mathematical reality that if
the republicans are the ones who are not
protected they are the ones who are
overwhelmingly going to get sick
and they are overwhelmingly the ones who
are going to die
was marjorie taylor green's apology
sincere
let me know you can find me on twitter
at d pacman i think the answer is
obviously no
i think it got to the point where even
for her level
of tolerating being critiqued uh and
criticized
she realized i should probably apologize
for this but then within days really
going right back to the same analogies
and illusions the nazis
and the holocaust and hitler just
disgusting completely disgusting stuff
let's take a quick break we've got a
packed show for you
we'll be right back one of our sponsors
is blast light the smallest and most
convenient uv disinfection light on the
market
covet is not over there are new variants
there might be future resurgences so of
course
it's still important to take precautions
keep yourself safe keep people around
you
safe uvc lights have been proven to
safely and rapidly kill bacteria
mold fungi and viruses including covet
19.
blast light is a convenient keychain uvc
light that you can take
wherever you go i keep it attached to my
keys
it goes everywhere with me it's easy to
use it disinfects any surface in just
seconds
with a really long battery life and it's
rechargeable i've looked at a bunch of
different uvc light
options and this is by far the most
compact and portable one
out there blast light is normally 99 but
my audience can get it for 40 percent
off
which comes to 59.50 when you go to
davidpakman.com
blastlight the link is underneath this
video
remember that the best way to support
the work we do is simply grab a
membership at joinpackman.com it's
painless it really really is
and you can sign up with the coupon code
indictment21
yes trumpcfo very powerfully indicted
uh sign up there and we will see you on
the bonus show
let's hear from some people um some of
our viewers via discord you can join
the discord at davidpakman.com discord
why don't we start today
with andrew from miami andrew from miami
you're on the air
oh boy
andrew from miami you are on
the air
where is andrew that's the real question
hmm
no andrew from miami apparently
all right let's try oh i don't know
how about
isaiah from arca philadelphia i don't
know what that means isaiah you're on
the air
oh david can you hear me yes i can oh
actually um so there's a there's a town
called arkadelphia
so where i go to college it's not
actually where i am right now
arkhadelphia very good what state is
that yes um it's the state of arkansas
very good arkadelphia arkansas i'm
learning a lot here
um so i just had uh i wanted to get your
your thought on this yeah about
conspiracy theories
and so maybe a safe way of
talking about them rhetorically okay so
i'm trying to think about the best way
to to get to this but kind of as an
example
so there's the absolutely ludicrous ones
based and no
truth whatsoever that the people that
believe in them
are never going to not find a reason to
believe in them
and obviously those should be criticized
but then there's ones like the
epstein theories where personally and i
don't know why you believe in this but
personally
i think occam's razor says that
it's it seems that there's more evidence
saying
that there's that the cause of death is
not what is being stated
i have not uh i have not been convinced
of that
we did a segment where we looked at a
bunch of claims made by a foreign
forensic pathologist
and if you just listen to the claims and
accept them
it certainly sounds that way but then
when i actually researched
each claim like for example one claim
was
the hyoid bone never gets broken in a
hanging suicide but then you research
that and it's like oh
actually half the time it does get
broken in a hanging suicide so i i've
you know when i looked more into it i
came away
not feeling like it was i think the
circumstantial questions are much
stronger than some of that stuff but
anyway maybe it's not really the point
that case isn't as an example so like as
you said like
so if i saw that evidence i would be
willing to change my mind
yeah i would stay based on on the
evidence i'd presented fair i guess
my question is how do we safely
discuss one type of like
suspicious thing that maybe is not
accepted as mainstream but
want to investigate and think about kind
of well in what way is it unsafe i mean
when you say how can we safely do it
where would the lack of safety come from
so i guess what what i mean is that um
and i was just using epstein as one
particular example
but um when you talk about so
like there's mk ultra which was a very
very real thing used to be a conspiracy
theory
a lot of people that talk about these
kinds of things online these communities
they're toxic communities that because
one thing
may have some truth to it it drags
people into other conspiracies and so
how do we kind of talk about one thing
that we think
i think there may be something more to
this let's look into it
without being dragged into the
total nonsense part here's the reality
the non-conspiracy there are people who
are just
conspiracists they love conspiracism
and we've talked about them with experts
on the show
those people are rarely just going to
say
let me examine this one thing and
just go where the facts take me because
they are by their nature
conspiracists the way to safely do it is
just for non-conspiracists
to evaluate all of these things right
like i don't consider myself a
conspiracist
i don't just fall down i don't think hey
you know what
um wuhan lab leak no evidence of a bio
weapon that it was developed and
released on purpose
it's plausible and all along i've said
it should be looked into
whether the virus was being researched
in a lab and it accidentally
leaked and someone got scratched and
infected or whatever
okay i'm not falling for flat earth i'm
not doing
vaccine conspiracy you know if people
like you and i
the the safe way to do it would be for
people like you and i to just examine
these things and to go where the
evidence takes us
and it sound i can say for myself and it
sounds like you're the same way
you don't just get dragged down any
conspiracy path just because someone
mentions it
tell it okay good important question
i'm gonna move on because i do have so
many people uh
waiting why don't we go today
uh let's go to joseph from seattle
joseph you're on the air
stand back and stand by joseph
all right no joseph today not off to a
great start
let's go to lj from las vegas
lj you were on the air morning david can
you hear me
i can hear you fine sir sir how are you
doing
good i'm gonna call in a couple times so
i'm just
want to give you a call back and i saw
your video on youtube so i just wanted
to see if i
could get in thank you well we are here
we are here
i just wanted something to kind of give
a comment to the last discussion you had
um there's also another part of
conspiracy theories that we should also
be
uh you know be aware of okay is never
have a conversation
with uh about fire safety with an
arsonist so also depends on
necessarily who's having the discussion
that where you would basically have
those discussions on conspiracy theories
that's a very good point yeah and maybe
to like go with the covid lag
lap leak stuff or whatever like there's
a big contingent
that is pro-trump who feel
that if covid was a bio weapon created
in china
that it would then excuse trump's total
mishandling of the virus like they have
a political motivation now
i simply disagree that it would no
matter where covet came from trump
mishandled it
but they have a very particular interest
in pushing one narrative
and so i think you're absolutely right
that we should we should consider the
motivations of people pushing certain
ideas
absolutely um actually i'm um to to
discuss trump a little bit i do feel
that in the media right now at the
moment there seems to be some kind of
fanaticism with discussing everything
that he does even though he's been
removed from facebook he's been removed
from twitter
um you know however short term those
removals are
there seems to be like almost this dream
that he comes back so that way they can
receive some more you know ratings
some more i review you know like more
watch time from
uh the audiences out there because he
was so good for them
yeah i mean i'd have i'd want to hear
more about who you think is hoping trump
comes back
i actually am really worried that he
comes back earlier this week i did a
segment explaining
i think that if there's a rematch of
2020 and 24
that it's very bad for joe biden i i
have a really hard time believing that
joe biden is going to do well in a
rematch against trump in 2024
for reasons i laid out if joe biden says
i'm not running
and it's kind of handed to kamala i
think that
that would be really tough if if trump
runs so i'm actually i'm hoping the
opposite you know i've said before in
terms of my level of coverage
this guy has done things that arguably
should
should have gotten him arrested at
minimum and
he has lost almost no support from the
republican party that's really scary
that's a that's a problem with american
culture right now
and so i'm covering him to the extent
that i do because
he's relevant and he may be the king
maker in 22 and he may run in 24 and if
he
runs i think it's conceivable that he
will win but in terms of ratings i mean
i'm more concerned with like what's good
for the country
and trump coming back would be very bad
for the country so i don't want it
oh absolutely i completely agree it just
it seems like
and you know it fox news already covers
them all the time
right that's not the issue i'm talking
about it's just i feel like
when he puts out one of his long-form
tweets the the presidential releases
whatever they're called right yep yep
it's there's a romanticism that people
say it's like oh can you believe he's
still saying this i'm like yes
he said it for four years we already
know that yeah
i agree with you yeah yeah and with
those statements i mean we
we've basically started ignoring them
when they're relevant to something
happening bigger picture in the news
you know we'll include it as part of a
commentary but yeah i mean i think that
there's some channels where like
every day he's putting one out and
they're reading it and then doing
interviews on its basis that seems to me
like
maybe a little bit a little bit over the
line
absolutely so that's all i just want to
comment on i love the show
uh have a great day all right thank you
very much yeah good
okay let's go next to oh where do we go
how about uh
oh you know where let's go to i hope i'm
pronouncing this correctly
is it koya from virginia
yes it is how are you uh very good um
i would say and you but you sorry sudden
you're doing fine
thank you what's what's going on so i
actually had two questions if that's all
right and i'll try my best to keep it
brief but
sure um it'll depend on the duration
yeah fair enough
um i had a question about the filibuster
and pride month and black history month
first i'll
go ahead and start with the filibuster
okay but
with the filibuster even on the left
there is both
agreements and disagreements to keep it
of course the right wants it because
then
you know all the republicans can you
know continuously block things as they
have for decades now of course
um but just the same on the left the
concern is that if we remove the
filibuster that suddenly republicans
will have a much easier time pushing
legislation
as we should be able to do so i was
wondering on your thoughts about that i
think that the concern that if you just
destroy the filibuster it then comes
back
and hurts democrats more than it helps
them today
is a completely realistic and practical
concern and
part of why it's practical and realistic
is that
republicans have shown that they do not
care
about how their political maneuverings
are perceived
their side will not punish them for
doing one thing when it's obama's
supreme court nominee
and a different thing when it's trump's
and then saying if if biden gets one
we'll do a different thing again
their side won't hold them accountable
for the dirty tricks and the hypocrisy
and the maneuverings
so because democrats have not shown a
willingness to sort of get down in the
mud in the same way i'm not saying stoop
to their level when it comes to
corruption and immorality but
simply when it comes to doing what you
have to do to get political victories
i would be very worried that the appeal
of getting rid of the filibuster right
now
to get a couple things passed would
disgustingly backfire in the future
which is why i end up thinking there
should be
a reformed filibuster that requires it
to actually be a talking filibuster that
will then
as it goes longer and longer uh start to
be news
and maybe start to have some political
consequences for republicans like really
make them work for it
that's why i end up where i end up
versus just blowing it up altogether and
it's very practical it's
i assume because democrats are so
incompetent
it will backfire against them i see
already so uh moving on to my
second question in regards to pride
month and black history month
sure there always seems to be a lot of
corporate interest involved in that
and to me i consider it like it presents
a danger to
me and my other fellow community members
as well as just to
even you know straight people and this
is more in regards to pride history
month i'll get on to black history month
in the moment but
people in the community know
usually no better than to fall for the
corporate interest that is
put rainbows on everything sell it here
this is how you support the
community yet at the same time
none of the proceeds ever actually go to
any um
uh you know uh commun or not communities
uh any sort of i forgot the word i'm
sorry
basically any kind of causes yes thank
you okay um that can actually help
people in return the likes of you know
suicide hotlines for trans and you know
of course uh gay individuals
uh so on and so forth as well as just
you know in regards to even trained
surgery because that stuff is expensive
especially in america
um it's just they they only do it for
themselves and i wonder what your
you know thoughts are on that and even
in regards to advice that you may give
to other people because they mainly
um prey on straight people saying this
is how you can support
other lgbtq members whenever i've talked
to yeah so i have
a bunch of segments on this i've
basically i mean i've likely
likened it almost to like a fraud fraud
because
it is it is just it it it's
it's a business decision is all it is
and many of these businesses uh have a
long history of donating
to anti-gay politicians while at the
same time celebrating pride month so
yeah check out my clips on it i've
talked about it extensively
alrighty thank you all right thanks very
much um i'm gonna move on cause i have
so many people waiting i appreciate
the call we will take a quick break and
then we'll be right back with more
in in mere moments so if you're holding
to talk to me don't hang up
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show
the regular show with no commercials you
also get access to our entire archive
of every episode dating back a really
long
time and plenty of other awesome
membership perks go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount join pacman.com
all right let's go back to the phones
via discord not really phones uh and
talk to a few more people you can find
it at davidpakman.com
slash discord let's go
next to let's go to
alacrity from alabama you're on the air
greetings mr pacman it's a pleasure to
be here i shall be swift
i come here because i seek your opinion
of a relatively new tax proposal called
the chaos tax
and to briefly debate its merits as a
gesture of good faith
know that i will judge your arguments
judiciously
okay anyway
the chaos tax is a tax proposal where
[Music]
you have different revenue pools and you
tailor the rates to that revenue pool
and it
is a range of rates bounded and the
rates are tailored to minimize
compliance costs
and administrative costs and it is
called a chaos tax because within those
bounds there is
randomization and application like say
from people who pay it
and an example of revenue pool would be
just financial transactions
or sales something like that and
this does sound a bit of a bizarre
proposal but there is precedent for
randomization and
tax puzzles for example there was this
one type of tax i
forgive me the exact name eludes me
but it was a sort of prophet's tax an
example given
on the source that i was reading is that
you is that it was applying it to
corporations
and that's the randomization helped
minimize
the cost of either compliance or
actually just minimize dead weight loss
due to economic distortions from the tax
so i'm just wondering what you think of
a tax of this nature
i don't even know that i understand it
are you saying that for a given group
like for example corporations the tax
rate they pay
is subject to basically chance where
some corporations randomly pay 11
and others pay 17 and you don't know
until you file your taxes
it wouldn't be like that no because the
entire point of the tax
which is it would only be applied to
pools such as financial transactions
where the cost of trying to account for
it like you said will be lower than if
you just
didn't bother trying to account for it
for example there was this one case i
believe it was from the 70s
where this person made millions of
dollars skimming from the rounding
errors in bank transactions so the
tax is meant to be is not meant to be
filed by
the people paying it for that very
reason because in that case the one that
you just cited
if you actually have to file it the cost
of not accounting for it or greater
than just not ignoring it you know i
apologize i have no idea what you're
talking about i just i
and this may be my i may have a
cognitive deficit i just have no
clue at all how what you're talking
about would work so let me study it and
then i'll follow up okay
well it is a tax proposal of my own
creation so i can send you the
literature that i have compiled ah
this is something you've come up with
yes okay
all right good send me the literature
and then
um you know we will we will we will
figure it out okay
come on man all right then all right
thank you very much let's see who else
is on today
um why don't we speak next to
um let's speak to logan from eureka
logan you're on the air hey can you hear
me yes i can
hey how are you doing dave i'm doing
well cool
i just wanted to get your general take
on the upcoming
california gubernatorial recall
a lot of the sentiment i get i i'm a
bartender personally so i get a lot of
um
quips from my local community
and it seems like in general people
don't know what they're talking about as
far as
uh why this is happening
and uh why do you think people hate
gavin newsom so much
is mostly what my my question is you
know to me this recall effort makes no
sense whatsoever california
is growing uh almost as quickly over the
last six seven years
as the developing country of china um
economically california is doing really
well
um i it to whether whether you believe
it's because of gavin newsom
or not that's something that can be
debated but it seems to me
that i would be looking at california
saying wow on a lot of fronts things are
looking good they've got a surplus
they've got a lot of interesting
initiatives
now those on the right like to say
you've got homelessness in cities
um it's really expensive in california
etc you know it's expensive because
there's demand
there the the very people who talk about
markets
seem not to understand it's expensive in
california because a lot of people want
to go to california that's why
uh property values are as high as they
are is that bad for tons of people of
course it is
and we should deal with that we should
deal with a housing program we should
deal with all these things but
i am seeing nothing going on in
california that says to me
the governor is uniquely failing and
needs to be removed before
his term would even be up so you'd have
to ask someone who wants to do it
because it makes no sense to me
yeah that's that's pretty much where i'm
at but um yeah thanks for responding
my pleasure uh yeah we'll continue to
follow that
and see what happens let's go next
to oh how about veronica veronica what's
on your mind today
hello
veronica oh no
sam cedar all right no veronica today
that's too bad
let's go to thomas from
um thomas from vietnam i believe is that
right thomas
um yes how are you how you doing
uh fantastic fantastic i've been a big
fan of your show for over a year now
thank you you're you're what what kind
of a phone are you calling through
because it is a very strange sound
i'm i'm i'm using how me beautiful
right um so i have two questions and the
first one
um um concerning the republican party
with it with the current state of
politics
you see who will be the one who could
you know like actually turn around the
policy
and make it less of a you know atrocity
that it is now
i you know there's there's two ways to
think about that yeah what republican
could get
the republican party out of trumpism one
school of thought it is that it has to
be a tried and true republican
someone like uh you know mitt romney or
um some like the return of paul ryan for
example has been talked about
in that bucket i lean more towards
something like the return of paul ryan
would be one possibility
for getting maybe the republican party
out of trumpism in a slightly credible
way
the other path would be a new young
cadre of republicans
that are very different than the
trumpian ones so
not like madison cawthorne not like
lauren beaubert that it that it should
come from the youth of the republican
party the problem is the youth of the
repub republican party from what i'm
seeing
are suffering from some pretty
weaponized disinformation
so i i i think that if you said to me
paul ryan's the type of guy who could
maybe pull the republican party out of
trumpism i might i might go with that i
might at least think that's a
plausible idea well well i think we
could have students to
wait and see how it goes
yes we certainly um my second question
is
also about comparison because i'm i
noticed that recently in vietnam the
there's been a common import of trumpism
and also q anon to
do certain exams oh boy because we we
are we are rolling out
uh vaccines um nationally
but there are a lot of anti-vaccination
uh movements are
going under the radar and it is
connected with
with you know trump supporters also
connected to a certain extent with
multi-level marketing as well uh so a
lot of these
this you know community with with cold
life kind of
activities they are being like
put together uh in in this sort of
confusing theories
anti-vaccination kind of thing so you
know
how do we break that up i i don't know
how we break it up but i love that
you're bringing up multi-level marketing
because there is actually a
big overlap between anti-vaxxers and the
types of people that fall for
mlms uh and who
often there's mlms that are
pseudoscience so it actually is not
shocking to me that you would have mlm
people who think that essential oils and
who the hell knows what
will cure conditions thinking that they
don't need to take the vaccine so i'm
sorry it's happening in vietnam i am
going to let you go because the
connection is getting worse and worse by
the second
but uh that the connection between mlm
and anti-vaxx
genuinely does not surprise me that
actually
makes a lot of sense why don't we go
next to
colin from oregon colin you're on the
air
hi can you hear me okay yes i can
beautifully
oh thank you wow this is really amazing
i've never done anything like this
well let's do it uh so well i'm curious
usually you do this on fridays are you
doing it on a wednesday what's going on
we always do it on wednesday for the
friday show
oh really yeah oh i thought so i
cuz i remember you i was watching you
said well we do this live so i was under
the impression that you shoot the shows
the day that you post them is that not
true it's not true with the calls
because sometimes we like extra time
just in case we need to if
in case they're really bad like for
example let's say this call didn't go
anywhere we would have time to like cut
it and film something else
oh sure because i'm sure you get some
people maybe they call them they really
don't know what to say
yeah sometimes it happens well it's
funny because your nerves act up because
they're like okay i'm talking with a
radio person uh this person makes a
whole career talking
and you're like well i listened to your
show i'm actually a recent listener
and you're getting me into politics
beautiful
so i'm really kind of new at this um but
i do have a good question for you i hope
it's a good question
good so the reason i don't watch a lot
of conservative news well i do watch it
but i just i feel like the way they
present information
is so aggressive yes i completely
i i when you said when you said i
believe the way they present information
i was thinking aggressive in my mind and
then you said it i agree
and the thing is a lot of people like
that a lot of people like the idea that
hey trump's a big man and ben shapiro
talks quickly
and stephen crowder wears a gun bra
while he
talks and so this is like yeah it
doesn't even matter
what they say it's how they're saying it
i can a hundred percent agree with you
now so let's talk about uh conservative
religion now you also talked about
um you are jewish correct
yeah yes i'm ethnically jewish and
culturally jewish i'm not religious
but so we talk about uh religious
ideology um
we talk about the praise and worship the
high and mighty the uh we give our souls
and so i find a lot of conservative
religious uh
ideas to be like well you don't need to
understand why
you just believe okay right
so maybe conservative tries to appeal to
that by being like you guys
you got uh even ted cruz was like
for us to go against the woke we need to
wake up and it's like okay
um i'm confused i'm i'm confused as well
but you are absolutely spot on that
there's this
aggressive nature to the presentation
from a lot of these right wingers
and uh it for for me it's just a i mean
it's like
i wouldn't be agreeing with them either
way but
um i completely find it off-putting but
it's a feature not a bug
for for many on the right all right
colin thank you i appreciate the call
that's all the time we have today so if
i didn't get to you
consider uh this an apology but we will
take phone calls again
thanks everybody quick break and then
we'll be right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow
all right let's get into audience
questions for the week very
important political issues and many
other things to talk about
really important issue right off the top
relates to foreign policy i got a bunch
of questions that were basically some
version of this
why do trump supporters suddenly
not want us to leave afghanistan which
joe biden is doing
given that it was donald trump's idea
do you you really don't know the answer
to this one i mean listen guys the
they liked it when it was trump's idea
but not when it's joe biden doing it
uh look at the iraq war george w bush in
2003
uh says doesn't actually say but
says even though it was not iraq that
attacked us on 911
george w bush says we're going to go
into iraq and whether it was trying to
finish
what his father george h.w bush left
undone
or a cynical political ploy because
uh saddam hussein was widely seen and
accurately so is not a particularly good
guy whatever the reason was
at that time if you questioned what the
hell are we doing in iraq
you were called unpatriotic you were
accused of not supporting the troops etc
in comes trump and trump says hey you
know what i was against going into iraq
that was a disaster
i'm gonna fix the republican party i'm
not gonna do stupid stuff like george w
bush and
by and large his followers in 2015 2016
fell for that which 13 years before
would have been unthinkable in most
republican circles except for some like
more extreme
traditional libertarian circles uh
that's what democrats have been saying
all along but when trump says it
they believe it and it's the exact same
thing with afghanistan
trump said we're getting the hell out of
afghanistan
and i'll talk about whether that makes
sense in a moment but hint it does
um and then when joe biden came into
office and at the time
republicans sort of said they liked it i
mean i guess joe biden came in and said
listen i'm not saying we're not getting
out of afghanistan but trump is such a
buffoon
my words not his i'm pausing everything
trump was doing to review it
and then i'll make a decision and joe
biden made the decision
he's going to keep going with the
afghanistan withdrawal and
uh it will the announcement was instead
of being in may which was trump's idea
it will be by september 11th a delay of
about four months
even though it appears to be happening
more quickly and will be done roughly
similarly to when donald trump was it's
basically the same thing that joe
biden's doing is what donald trump is
doing but now
all these republicans and trumpets are
saying whoa hold on a second
joe biden has no plan for how to get out
did trump he just said we're leaving joe
biden is getting out in a way that could
leave a vacuum
that's always been the concern what's
new about that
so they're just pathetic political
statements
i wouldn't pay too much attention to
them for the most part
foreign policy in this way
i don't believe is really even going to
play a role in 2024 unless something
dramatically changes
um so it's it's very transparent
cynicism
uh and the analysis is super simple they
they liked it when trump was doing it
when biden's doing it by definition it's
not good because biden
as they see it is incompetent and won't
do it the right way
now in terms of getting out it's just
time
and i've said for a long time when you
break something you own it then you got
to fix it
and so when uh this applied to
afghanistan and the supply to iraq when
you go in
as the united states did and wreak havoc
and cause chaos
without even evaluating whether your
motivations were good or bad like i'm
not even including that in this
conversation as relevant as it is
if you cause the chaos you have some
responsibility to fix it
and the question then becomes
how many years how many administrations
worth and at a certain point
particularly when you realize
just staying won't fix it you have to
say this is as far as the responsibility
goes and it's time to get out so
are we responsible for the state of
affairs currently in afghanistan as well
as in iraq of course
uh would our responsibility
dictate that we stay even if we only
continue to make it worse or at least
not better
i think there's a limit to it and i
think that limit has been reached 20
years
so it is time to get out things may go
downhill
as a result and that is going to have to
be dealt
with but at a certain point the
responsibility has to stop so the trump
supporters now saying biden shouldn't
get out but trump was and i liked it
then but i don't like it now
don't pay attention to them but there
are real serious questions
about the limits of american
responsibility
when we get into these quagmires abroad
and that's a much bigger topic for a
different day hey david if trump runs
third party do you think he can win
any states this is a really interesting
question because
i think the answer is is maybe yes i
mean listen if you if you look at
a variety of different states and you
pull
republicans and you say how many of you
would vote for trump
if he ran again for the most part trump
has more than 50
republican support i think in every
state i may be wrong
there may be some state where trump
wouldn't have 50 republican support
the math gets more complicated when you
realize that a trump
republican nomination in 24 and a trump
third party run in 2024 would
differently affect
republicans independents and democrats
so let's take it one
by one if trump is the republican
nominee
i think that that will motivate more
democrats to vote
against him than if trump runs as an
independent because democrats will see
trump as an independent
as less of a threat than trump as a
republican
okay if trump uh is the
um republican nominee i think that
independence will go more away from
donald trump where if his trump
is where is trump if trump is an
independent or third party
uh candidate it might actually attract
some independents who otherwise would
have said no no no this is not for me
i'm gonna vote for the democrat
and then for republicans and this is
where it gets really hard to predict
if trump is the republican nominee in
2024
i think he has almost all republican
support every poll is indicative of that
but if trump runs as an independent
about 60 percent of republicans in a
poll a couple of months ago
said they would follow trump to a third
party or or an independent status
i don't know that i believe them i
genuinely am unsure that they would
actually
follow through with that so all of these
are complicated scenarios
now could trump as a third-party
candidate win some states
yeah i think it's possible i think it's
possible that he would
but the real question is what does it do
in terms of getting to 270 and to me
it seems abundantly clear that the math
of a trump third party run points one
way and one way only
which is a massive democratic victory uh
in particular if trump because
remember scenario one is that you've got
a democratic candidate which who wins
the normal blue states and then the
republican nominee
and third party trump split the red
states
okay that's that's one scenario but even
without winning a single state donald
trump as a third party candidate could
absolutely destroy the republican party
because if you think of all those states
where trump
won but by half a point or trump won
by one point or by three points or even
four
if trump can pick up even 10 15
support from republicans in some of
those states
they split the vote and you end up with
a situation
like a democrat having you know 48
but having a plurality and the other 52
percent being divided by trump and the
republican nominee so
personally i uh my my view as stated
earlier this week is
if trump runs against biden in 24
and trump's the republican nominee i
think it's very bad for joe biden
and i laid it out in detail earlier this
week if biden says
i'm only going to be doing one term vote
kamala and kamala is handed the
nomination
i think that's very bad for kamala
harris i think trump likely does very
well in that scenario
so in that sense i want trump to not be
involved at all but
trump has a third-party candidate a
viable one who could get again
10 12 15 of the vote in some of these
key states
it gives the election to the democratic
candidate and i've seen no
credible mathematical explanation of why
that is not the right assessment
if you have one i want to hear from you
is there any scenario where trump
getting 12 nationally as a third-party
candidate
doesn't obviously become uh just a
windfall for the democratic candidate
let me know i want to hear from you
hey david you've been covering some of
trump's 2021 rallies do you think
his 2021 rallies will be as effective as
they were in 2016. so couple different
things
the point of the 2021 trump rallies is
very different than 2016. in 2016 trump
was
running for president in 2020
trump was running for president the
rallies were about vote for me
sometimes begrudgingly he would say okay
maybe vote for some of these
senatorial or or congressional
candidates that came out as well but
basically it was
vote for me right now although we can
imagine that the point of the trump
rally
from last week or the one you know
whatever the next one's going to be
it's sort of to set up a 2024 run
really it's something else it's one to
feed trump's ego which has been
significantly damaged by being kicked
out of the white house by
joe biden so it's an emotional thing for
donald trump number two
it is setting up the grift of donating
money to the
the pack or however they're organized
where trump will decide who are the good
republicans not the rhinos worthy of my
support of your support
that's going to be a a part of it and
then three
it will be to still be the decider
but less as a candidate and more is the
person that will
give what he considers to be a very
valuable endorsement to 2022
candidates and there's a couple
differences also between now and 2016 in
terms of trump's perception in 2016
trump was basically sort of eccentric
celebrity
and there were lots of people who just
wanted to be in close contact with trump
and that drove interest in trump in 2015
2016
and um made the rallies maybe more
powerful than they're going to be
right now um there is more trump fatigue
at this point and in addition to that
there are also more people who are kind
of over the celebrity aspect of trump
and um i mean listen if you're at this
point if you're
under 30 i would say if you're under 26
you really see trump more as that
president guy who's no longer president
than as a real estate mogul in the 80s
in new york city
and there is some sense i have that
again i go back to it because i think
it's so dangerous
ron desantis is a guy who could really
challenge trump
not just in an electoral sense if it
came to it in 2024
but he has a lot of the same horrible
authoritarian tendencies as trump but
he's more competent
and he's a better speaker and this makes
him
i believe significantly more dangerous
the problem for some
in some sense for republicans is that
for now they're
stuck with trump as a leader whether
they want him or not
until someone else surfaces so even
though we can pull republicans right now
and
you know 70 say they'd vote trump again
30 say they wouldn't
that 30 percent has not coalesced around
anyone in particular
and if and until that happens trump
trump's control of the republican party
is his for the taking
he will never let go of power he will
he'll bring down
the ship with him and in a sense he did
right i mean the republican party lost
the house in 2018
the senate in 2020 the white house in
2020 under trump
trump sees himself as great for the
party he talks about his endorsements
are worth so much etc so
trump will destroy the party if it's up
to him will someone remove him from that
position of power
and in the end the rallies are going to
be more of a revenue generating activity
and a way to placate trump's broken ego
than they are at least in 2021
electorally significant for donald trump
that's my sense if you see the modern
trump rally is something different
then let me know we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today
how do you get the bonus show it's so
easy you just sign up at joinpakman.com
that is it
sign up at joinpakman.com use the coupon
code better21 if you would like
and we will see you in near seconds on
today's bonus gun
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blast light is
the world's
smallest and most convenient uvc
disinfection light to help keep you safe
against covid19 i take mine everywhere i
go
go to davidpakman.com blastlight to get
it for
40 off the link is down below